so last night i got to talk to priscilla
presley at the hotel she was hanging out
and i don't get star struck but i was
actually a little star struck yeah just
talking to her and i and like you know i
was in the presence of someone like it
just it meant a lot to me i can't
imagine what it was like for you
portraying her in a movie and meeting
her and everything that went along with
it so how long did it take for you to
sort of get over your nerves in your you
know like become
able to do this i mean
initially
yeah i was very nervous but i also you
know you get the role you sort of knew
what you were sort of stepping into at
the same time i think you know knowing
that she was going to see the film it
always
felt like she was you know standing over
my shoulder watching every decision that
i was making um but honestly you know
baz and everyone at basmark and cm
austin and tom there was such a wealth
of knowledge and so i felt
like the you know
there was a lot of love surrounding this
film and that's where it was made from
and so i feel like only good things can
happen when people make
make you know creative endeavors out of
a place of love and respect and so i
felt good about that
coming into meeting her in person i
obviously was very very nervous but she
was beautiful and lovely and it's been a
pleasure to get to know her uh if you
could have hypothetically taken
something home from set because the
costumes in this movie are adequately
insane right they're out of control um
what would you have taken and why the
70s outfit that i wore uh with
the badass like with the baju or the
bejeweled like the vegas special sure
with the what do you call it the beaded
garment it was one of my most favorite
things to wear it was like i just felt
so beautiful in it and it made noise it
was like just a really fun outfit to
wear if i was an actor and i was wearing
an outfit like that
are you tempted like were you tempted at
all like to go to the local supermarket
and just walk around and be like i mean
check this out it's funny we were
shooting next to movie world right
that's where the studio is in in on the
gold coast and i want really wanted us
to do one of the rides in full elvis and
priscilla get up because i just thought
it would be funny but we weren't allowed
to
so no i wish i wish
i would imagine when you were like
researching and getting ready to make
this there were a lot of things you
learned that really surprised you what
were one or two of the things that you
were like oh my god like really really
surprised i mean first and foremost i
didn't know how heavily that elvis was
inspired by black culture and black
music i had no idea that that's where
his music came from i didn't know much
about bb king about big mama thought and
about um little richard either how much
you know that there would be no elvis
without them i think that was something
that sort of
resonated with me and i sort of you know
went into um yeah it was just really
really interesting for me to learn about
that and the other thing i think with
priscilla was um
[Music]
learning about her fieriness and her
feistiness i think you know you know
with with pretty girls and history with
beautiful women we can
often you know solidify them as sort of
two-dimensional beings and i think that
that learning that about her it was it
brought breadth um to my interpretation
of her i always think every movie has
deleted scenes it does was there
anything that you were sad to see go
that you actually filmed so many things
you know we did um we recreated the
jungle room which is crazy because we
were there last night and i walked in
because we wouldn't had dinner at
graceland and um we walked into the into
the jungle room and i was like i've been
here before because we we recreated the
exact same set you know on the gold
coast it was mad so there was that and
there was also some beautiful stuff that
we did um at a dinner table after uh
after he sort of i don't want to give
any spoilers away but but um at the
dinner table there's a there were some
scenes at a dinner table which didn't
make it into the final cut on that note
i'm just going to say a sincere
congratulations i thought this movie was
great um thank you so much for your time